you cannot say the word you can't say
rhymes with
you can't say like starts with but i can
give you any hint that i want
okay you just give me to guess it
all right best one-two duo in utah jazz
history john
john stockton farm alone
[Music]
uh jamal crawford's known for this to
move
crossover um
the chosen one lebron one finals out of
53
in 53 years wait what one
one one finals out of the last like 24.
kobe bryant okay all the best players in
the world
handlers the best players in the world
come on one team
two teams and play basketball okay
what happens when you get to the freezer
line foul
[Music]
um duke blue devils uh
coast guard
[Music]
i don't even know who that is last name
sounds like shrimp you can't do that
what what ryan sounds like
[Music]
uh short guy play for charlotte
[Music]
uh what college players do uh the
tournament what's it
uh final four the band the ncaa
tournament uh
no um it's like the same madness
uh it's a state it's a team
team yes all right it's a team that won
one finals in the last 50 years
i didn't know if i could say it's a team
i mean cleveland yes
that was your oh my god
you can do one skip you can skip one my
mom used to love this show i don't know
um what do you fry eggs in a pan okay
that's the last name now
a very common name before that is a
man or woman it's a dude okay peter pan
there you go
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh what is there a song three six mafia
they sing 36 mafia
36 mafia is a group that's not
um it's a superhero movie he
um it's johnny depp and he has pirates
of the caribbean no edwards is their
hands
uh eminem's movie hey mile so there's a
song so they sing this song
their most favorite song nelly said
hot in here there we go
50 cent in the club what's his game
crips
[Music]
um i shop here all the time that's where
i get most of my clothes from
it's retail it's not like high-end stuff
but
people resell their clothes here
julia roberts played a like a pretty
woman legal assistant
uh in a lawsuit aaron brockovich
um halle berry was this role uh the
opposite of batman
catwoman yes three sick mafia is a group
[Music]
oh so this is that um
ball dude um i don't know any of this
song bro white skin
robber good voice hello
[Music]
i think easter bunny but with the person
in the name
peter rabbit uh football texas odessa
texas
[Music]
um oh the magic carpet magic carpet
aladdin
[Music]
i mean all rappers and artists dropped
certain projects it's called a
album
okay um this was a movie with
jennifer lopez she's planning i don't
even know this no that's a different
movie
that's the wedding planner
winning crashes uh my best friend's
wedding yes
i froze
[Music]
explain why you thought 3 6 mafia and
bone thugs and harmony like what was the
correlation there
because i just the song like the fly i i
i i like i just always thought that was
like bone thugs and harmony so
i don't know how i thought 36 mafia was
a song that
i don't know i'ma just take the l on it
i mean
fair you know it was right before my
time
so i'll take the l but it's all good